。
嗯。
来今天讲这个保你平安。首先说一下啊，为什么选了这部片子，这个电影从剧本的角度啊非常成功，是一个非常完整的呃，带有呃很浓重的商业色彩一个原先点啊，非常符合我们我们学习编剧啊，学习写剧本的创作思路。
就我们作为编剧啊，就应该写写这样的剧本，这样的剧本好卖好卖，这是第一件事情。第二件事情呢，这部个电影呢确实也没有受到足够的重视啊，当然了，票房肯定也是打几亿啊，肯定也是接近10亿左右吧。我没有仔细问啊。所以这部片子啊呃不管是票房还是评分其实都没有到达，应该有的一个高度。
都比他的实际水平要少一点。啊，至于为什么咱们当然也可以讨论，可以研究啊。第三个原因，为什么看这部片子呢？是因为这部电影在上映之后呢，嗯我曾经和大鹏导演两次啊花了两个下午的时间嗯仔细的复盘过这部电影。
就关于这个创作的过程，包括遗憾，包括当时的一些选择啊，重新的复盘。我们俩讨论了一下有没有其他的可能性啊，就关于这部电影，因为这部电影是他韩鹏导演这个这个自导自演的电影嘛，对吧？所以说呃他也最有发言权啊。
那从这个角度呢，我把从他那里得到的，或者是我们俩碰撞出来的一些想法啊，可以讲给同学们听。这样的话相当于你们跟跟创作者呢角度可以站得更近，更便于你们去学习。好吧，基于这几点原因啊，我们来看一下这部保你平安。
咱们拉片课其他都先不要说再来就聊一件事情，就是他的信息包，就是他有传达了多少信息节拍，是我们最先要表达的啊。我们来看一下，帮你平安的信息节拍。第一部分啊启程转合的启的部分，第一拍第一分钟做了一个洗车的一个出场戏啊，是一个老旧的一个奔驰啊，我们说这个老奔驰，这个白奔驰嗯，确实是挺。
挺扎眼的，挺细节的。嗯，一场车戏、洗车戏啊，包括他开车的戏。我们说一个电影啊开始第一拍一般来说交代呃主角的现状啊。当然了，如果有前史会稍微倒腾一点前史，在这个故事当中没有前史，它就是现状。那你说这个破车是不是。
是不是主角的现状呢？那肯定是主角的现状之一，对吧？就是曾经错过，然后这个车老了，其实这种现状还是非常有典型意义的。为啥呢？因为我邻居我邻居门口总是停着一辆特别老的，就是那种。
奔驰S还有一辆已经门都瘪了的老宾利，就这两个车啊啊，这个当年我绝对能够买好多套房子是吧，这个就能看出这个人以前是阔过的啊，然后第二拍第三分钟继续交代主角的现状，参加女儿的一个文艺汇演。这里呢也顺便把家庭关系啊交代了一下，包括他的这个孩子呀，前妻啊，对吧？前期现在的老王呀，然后嘞。
来来晚了，只能爬墙混进去啊，给女儿丢脸了。
来到第三拍，第5分钟继续交代会现状。但是回到的是工作的这个环境啊，嗯，它是一个墓地的销售啊。在这里呢他为什么回来呢？是因为遇到了这个核心事件啊，寒露千坟这个事儿。
来到第四拍。
第8分钟，他来到墓地和韩璐告别。
你可以理解啊。
韩露要迁坟这个事情，他开始是没打算阻止的，为什么？因为他来告别嘛，然后回忆起当年的情况，有一场回忆起，也回忆这个韩露选择这个目的的一个过程。
来到第五拍，也就是第11分钟修车的时候啊，跟女儿发信息，女儿发现了别人的一个。
栽赃的这么一个事儿啊，相当于发现了一个栽赃这么一个情况。然后呢，主角在女儿跟伙伴的共同刺激下，决定查一下真相，记不记得伙伴是谁啊？在这里刺激他的乔杉是吧？伙伴。
和女儿对他共同的刺激必须维权这个事儿。然后第六拍第13分钟调查第一个线索，也就是宠物店的店员啊交涉失败，同步呢也继续交代女儿这个乐团钢笔丢失事件啊。
然后来到第七拍，第16分钟。
他回到回到这个胡同里的家，呃，他的生存环境第一次出现了啊呃正常写一般会从这写起。同学们。
你自己想一想啊，第七排才回到家，如果是正常编剧写啊，很有可能就是从家里起床往外走。
开始一天的交代，然后开着破车出去，然后去参加女儿文艺汇演啊。在这里他放在第七排，然后呢同步交代女儿那边看她的直播。我们说女儿这条辅线啊，跟父亲这条线相互呼应。嗯，女儿这条线严格来说啊。
这个故事的主角肯定是。
平安哥，然后女儿这条线跟他相呼应，处理的是一样的事情。但是呢他不是主角。我们说像极了金石漂流记这故事的小府线是用来干啥的。在这个故事里面，平安哥这条线阻止韩露千坟，帮寒露恢复名誉。
制止网络谣言是平安哥这条线，他女儿制止校园里面的谣言。哎，你看也是制止谣言，事情是一样的。
但是呢那条线它不是主线呀，那怎么办嘞？那又一样，那没关系吧，就是他女儿，然后两个人呢互相帮助，互相沟通。然后那条线呢戏份少一点，起到一个点缀和呼应的作用。
另外，在这个戏里，大危机发生在女儿身上，也就是灵魂黑夜啊，主角这里当然也有灵魂黑夜，走投无路没有办法了。但是呢由于造成实际实质性的大伤害。
所以把灵魂黑夜。
放在。
女儿身上。
所以你可以理解在这种情况下啊，故事的主线和那个所谓的主线，实际上讲的是同一件事儿，都是恢复名誉。
对吧都是澄清事实。呃，刚才说第七拍第16分钟，这里啊，女儿看父亲的直播，两个人发生关联啊。然后嘞，大家呃他们发现寒露的这个谣言啊开始发酵了啊，寒露的谣言开始发酵了，然后。
诱惑他放弃寒露这件事情。同时呢给他的诱饵是什么呢？帮女儿。
这个治那个胎记啊，这里把那个胎记的伏笔点了，然后然后说动了，先给它抹去吗，说动了以后呢，明天上午就挖坟，来到第八拍，也就是第22分钟。
我们这个平安哥啊到孤儿院查找韩璐的亲人，因为马上就要挖坟了嘛，他到孤儿院去查找韩璐的亲人，看到了韩璐和男朋友的照片，在确认韩璐没有亲人之后，对吧？那就是去再看最后一眼，就签坟呗。来到第九拍，也就第23分钟正式开始迁坟。
然后平安哥发现了一个问题，就是隔壁这个冯总的弟弟呀，也就是葬在隔壁的这个照片的人啊，也就是为什么嫌弃韩璐要迁坟呢？是隔壁这个冯总嫌弃韩璐已坐台的。
就认为韩璐以前是坐台的，所以要把弟弟牵走。
但是呢平安哥发现了一个问题，这个所谓的冯总的弟弟的照片就是韩璐生前的男朋友。
那么就。
兑现了刚才这个伏笔，也明白了为什么韩露选择葬在这儿呢？就是想跟男朋友葬在一起。那你看这事儿就不一样了。对，我们的主角决定要制止这件事情，也就是说正式上路来到第十拍啊，故事的第二部分。
我们的主角启程去找冯总交涉啊，这里是正式上路了。
想理清楚事情的缘由，然后呢争取到了4天的时间来查这个事情啊，第1一拍第30分钟。
再次到宠物店找tony，然后获取了下一个线索，也就是第二个线索扮演吉祥物的大猩猩和哥斯拉。
然后第十2拍32分钟。
另外一条故事线，女儿那里纠结要不要帮同学伸冤，但是呢被要挟了，要挟的点肯定还是那个胎记嘛。
第十三拍来到第34分钟去接女儿。
接女儿啊又聊起寒露事件，再次得到女儿的认可，应该做正确的事儿。你看啊他一这个缺能量了就去找女儿是吧？
十四拍第36分钟。第二个线索呢指向了自己的妹妹啊，找到妹妹，获得了下一个线索杨玉婷这么。
第15拍42分钟被妹妹强制去检查这个性病啊。女儿呃因为妹妹怀疑她跟着这个坐台小姐有一腿嘛，线索再次指向一个姓金的董事长，然后来到第16拍45分钟，外部的环境持交代了一下外部环境啊，持续的恶化，包括平安哥的老板。
啊，种种外部环境都对主线任务不利。这里单独拉一盘啊，交代了一下外部环境，你也可以不拉。
第17拍48分钟。
来找这个下一个线索，这个所谓的金董事长跟这个金董事长呢反复摩擦，反复交涉，线索指向了小F小F呢在指向一个帖子，锁定了最终的线索叫完美先生421。
第1八拍来到58分钟，外部环境压力。
继续参加。
然后呢，同时也引起了对手的注意，对手加紧了危险，对手是谁啊？在这个故事里面，主角行动线的对手是谁啊？对，冯总是吧？我们来看一下啊，58分钟，这里外部环境持续恶化。
好，我们说啊外部环境持续恶化。同时其实还有一件事情是交代了平安哥也开始被网报了啊。因为这个故事的主题是网报。
呃，来到第19拍啊，59分钟，平安哥的妹妹也就是这个这个这个这个李雪琴这个角色啊。
魏如意。
呃，四又完美先生以蛇出洞，想要引蛇出洞，然后呢锁定了对方的大本营是一个一个一个一个网吧。
20拍来到60分钟，女儿呢又交代女儿那条线在同情这个受害者，由于要不要挺身而出。
然后呢，父女两个人通过直播，通过互相发信息，交叉，互相叙互相交叉的叙事啊。
21拍65分钟，我们刚才交代了这个对手急了啊步步紧逼，那65分钟对手得逞了。
雨夜千坟。
65分钟记不记得故事的正中间故事的终点啊呃就理论上的终点啊，在这个里面不是正中间冯总雨夜千坟，同时呢平安哥还不知情，还在那劝女儿也要做正确的事情。我们说这是故事的终点。
这个没毛病吧，千坟雨夜千坟是故事终点。这个大家应该在这个故事里面，应该所有人都找对了。有没有人找错了，我看一看来。
有没有人？
故事终点讲错找错了啊，来到第三部分，第22拍，也就是第68分钟，他发现人家冯总啊并没有动寒露的很，而是把自己的弟弟牵走了，是吧？你不是这个你不是不签吗？那我们签人家这个冯总也挺讲究的，没干坏事儿，对吧？
但是平安还是不想放弃，产生了一个新的目标。
平安产生这个新的目标，简直就是蹬鼻子上脸呀。
很多很多这个同学是不是在这儿有点失开始失去共情。人家冯总。
把自己的弟弟牵走了还不行吗？是不是人家不想折腾，但是我们这个非亲非故这个这个平安哥啊，呃不不抛弃，不放弃。
来到第23拍，也就是第70分钟，寺庙里正在做法事啊，平安哥平安哥过来交涉，交涉不成，把人家骨灰抢走了啊。
第24分钟啊，第24盘73分钟再次上路。我们说故事终点以后调整目标啊，它这里调整目标再次调已调整了目标了，就是情侣坟不能拆，然后来再次上路，就带这个骨灰盒开车去内蒙寻找寻找中真相。同时啊网络上就持续发酵，因为彻底成了网红事件了嘛。
各种谣言四起。
我们说这里再次上路就再配Bgm。
同学们啊，每次上路都配BGM商业片都是这么玩的，记不记得再看一眼啊，看一眼它是不是真的商业片再上路配BGM啊。
但确实是王党好，，造型也诙谐，事态也拿捏，所以呃走的应该是黑红的路线，但黑红也是红。
啊这种这种人其实见得多了啊，一茬接一茬的互联网没有机名。
他抱走的不是方丈，是方丈怀里的骨灰盒，是有过前科的还打了等还婆我云白露。
一杯酒两甲饮三五来兜顶讲世界第一。
光看到大能了吗？那警察不也挺眼熟吗？这里面客串的很多人都是都是有点来头的啊来。
其实是第25part来到74分钟，女儿在他的鼓舞下，也走进了校长室，伸张正义，进行了核实，澄清了事实，也承认了的确是他做的。第26拍76分钟，平安哥来到网吧，找到这个所谓的完美先生421，然后一场追逐戏，对方逃脱了。
27拍79分钟，女儿在学校里被人报复，被人霸凌了。
第28拍，平安哥遇到一个网红粉丝啊，就是杨迪演的那个角色呃，能提供新的线索。因为421不是跑了吗？能提供新的线索，给421下个套。第29拍来到第82分钟。
得到了女儿被欺负的消息，还被拍了视频，准备往回赶。
然后30拍84分钟啊，车抛锚。
就往回奔跑。
露宿荒野，嗯，这里就营造了一个灵魂黑夜的一个感觉吧，是吧？车也坏了啊，天也黑了，荒野奔跑，女儿被欺负哭喊啊。
灵魂黑燕。
来来到第四部分。
来到护事的第四幕。
第31拍。
也就是第85分钟。
再次遇到了那个所谓代表寒露的白马，然后追着追赶白马，找到了下一个希望，找到了牧民也找到了手机信号。第32拍86分钟联系上了女儿。
女儿她自己在那灵魂黑夜呢，人家女儿已经熬过去了，并没有很难过。女儿成长了，所以她从女儿处又获得了认可，获得了鼓励。她认为自己应该继续战斗。
第33盘来到88分钟，得到了421的新线索，还有半个小时就要逃跑了。在这里这最后高潮了吧，最后马上高潮了啊，加了一个时间锁，就是还有半小时，对方就要逃掉了。同时呢对手也追过来了，也就是那个玛丽啊冯总也逼近追过来了，然后夺车逃脱啊，夺车逃脱。
那第34拍来到第89分钟，被警车追赶啊，追车系，然后追到火车站，冲冲创安检，冲破安检。第35拍93分钟，遇到这个421再次开始追逐戏。
也就是所谓的高潮戏。
然后呢，但是这个追逐戏实在是用的太多了啊，动不动就追逐，动不动就追逐。那咋整呢？在这一场就加了一个直播视角，对吧？杨迪也跟着追手机视角、航拍视角，各种视角配合这个直播。
实际上呢这个高潮戏确实有点乏力，对吧？因为又是追逐，他们前面都追了好几回了。
来。
同时呢因为被这个这个这个高潮戏嘛，就所有对手也都到齐了啊，都把人聚一聚得了。呃，这个事儿不够人来凑。
36拍95分钟抓到了这个目标。
对手和警察也都赶到了啊，都带走了。
实际上就是任务完成了嘛。
但是任务完成嗯，不过瘾，第37拍第96分钟必须审问一下这个421啊，交代一下这个421所谓的作作案动机。
交代一下韩露的清白，顺便呢上一上价值，斥责一下这个网络这个付费啊，网络谣言这些事情。
第38拍98分钟。
平安跟冯总啊两个人一笑泯恩仇。
网络上呢也回归了正能量啊，这个这个这个因为这部电影啊毕竟还是要主旋律啊，因为有一个结局，所以网络上竟然也回归了正能量，所有人呢突就突然网络上的网民突然就都回归了正能量啊，突然就很善良。而且全民直播全民流量时代，又开始给网络唱赞歌，其实就是想说。
网络是两面的啊，这个这个有好的一面，也有坏的一面回归主题。第39part第100分钟啊，过生日接孩子放学，路边呢吃蛋糕啊第40part103分钟得到了韩璐预定的生日礼物，就韩璐提前几个月。
呃，因为要死了，提前几个月给这个这个平安哥嗯预定了生日礼物，然后配合着这个旁白，配合着这个音乐搞了一场烟花秀。哎呀，这也是国我们编剧的一个问题啊，一道要煽情，一道要最后弄一个美好的画面，就是烟花秀，咋整？
这个事儿吧就停留在90年代啊，停留在90年代的一种手法吧，就是烟花秀。然后到这里正文结束啊，40拍正文结束啊，105分钟啊然后。
最后又给了一个彩蛋啊，41拍107分钟。彩蛋呢里边有两个事情，一个事情就是。
这个孤儿这个女这个韩璐啊小时候就见过平安哥。
小时候他过生日的时候，就特别想喝一瓶可乐啊，当年就是年轻的善良的呃，平安哥曾经给他买过可乐，所以他是认得平安哥的。
你小孩认得大人吗？
嗯讲了一下韩露为什么这么执着于平安哥帮他，以及平安哥跟韩露特殊的这种情感关联，这是彩蛋的第一个作用。
彩蛋的第二个作用呢就是呃。
纪念了一下呃我们共同的好朋友。
赵英俊就是洒哥啊，因为洒哥前几年去世了啊，大鹏啊嗯徐峥哥呀，包括老薛啊薛之谦，我们几个跟洒哥关系都非常好啊，静静一下洒哥，我们先回到学习状态啊，我们先来看一下这个故事的主题吧。
我们说这个故事的主题有是网络暴力啊，遭受网络暴力的都是哪些人？同学们在这个故事当中，娘这个故事的创作者啊忘穿讲的是当前网络暴力这个情况啊，因为网络暴力确实对人的伤害非常大。对在这个戏里面都哪些人遭遇了所谓的网络暴力。
当然有寒路。
是吧当然我们的男主角啊，当然还有那个女儿，主要是讲这三个人啊，那这个故事的主题还是非常符合啊当前社会的一个很直接的一个东西啊。
我今天还看了一篇文章，说到底互联网是不是一场，是不是让人类走了一场弯路啊？有一些人在反思啊，特别2019年就开始有各种各样的研究和文章说互联网到底是不是人类的一场倒退啊有这样的一个说法。
嗯，同学们。
在这件事情上，我还是比较有发言权的啊。这个我们可以多说几呃，可以随便闲说闲扯几句。嗯，因为绝大部分人啊实际在生活当中会遭遇暴力，但是遭遇的到遭遇大面积的网络暴力其实没有那么明显啊。嗯，同学互联网对我的帮助很大。
我我甚至认为啊嗯没有如果没有互联网，可能我的人生路径会完全不一样。确实你如果在互联网上得利，或者是你在互联网上有一定的影响力，那么对你的暴力啊，那也是呃绝对是满满当当啊他是相伴相生的。所以说。
不能说呃因为吃到了互联网的红利呃，但是呢不愿意面对这个互联网的这个这暴利啊，你光光吃红利，不不吃暴利肯定是不可以的。网络暴力你根本呃阻止不了啊。很多同学由于你们没有被网络暴力暴力过。所以你们有很多时候啊。
根本体会不到什么叫网络暴力，甚至无意间都会参与网络暴力。包括我自己啊，我给大家举个最简单的例子。同学们，我给大家举个最简单的例子啊，网络暴力其实杀人于无形。
比如说恒大歌舞团的那几个女孩子，有人在乎真相吗？
有人在乎他们几个做过些什么事情吗？
有人在乎他们是真正是什么样的人吗？
没有吧。
但是他们几个人几乎就被网络毁掉了吧。
你觉得他们以后还能见人吗？
他们的生活现在是什么样的呢？
我们所有人都沉浸在一种正义当中，觉得应该谴责他们，应该骂他们，应该让他们体无完肤，应该拔他们。因为这个这个恒大欠了上万亿，对吧？因为但是有没有人真的关心真相呢？就那几个女孩子，而且那件事情是好几年以前的事情，但是没有人觉得。
没有觉人觉得真相重要，对吧？全都去全都去恨不得置他们于死地。当然了，大家会觉得哎，我就是转发了几下，我就是评论了几下，不会，但就是因为所有人集体的网报他们，他们几个活不成，你有没有想过这件事情，如果发生在你身上，你身边所有的人都认为你是一个。
你可能活不下去了，就所以网络暴力其实无处不在啊无处不在。
我们大部分时候是参与者，是施暴者。我们大部分时候啊，我们每个人都是施暴者来看一下这个故事的问题。有没有同学觉得这个故事的人物动机不够。这个故事我们说平安哥是吧？是一个刑满释放的目地消愁为了。
伸张正义啊，宁愿自己不要钱，不要工作，也要伸张正义，而且人家都躲了。
我走了，啊还要去继续追击总计问题。然后再思考一个问题，也是你们经常会犯的一个问题啊。同学们就是咱们有很多新手啊写剧本容易前半段长，后半段短，也就是一二目比较长，三四目比较短。然后一二目长呢。
是是因为写了一些无关紧要的阻力。比如说平安哥去找他妹妹拿一个线索，你说一个人去找自己的亲妹妹拿一个线索，会有很大的阻力吗？理论上不会，而且即便是会也不在主线去清商。但是在这里是写了很。
多的媳妇，比如鬼屋，比如送他去医院检查性病，然后平安哥去找下一个线索，贾斌啊这个角色。
贾编不见他们有理由吗？也没有理所以说这种不推进剧情的搞笑戏啊，替比较好写，所以就造成编剧在这里恋战啊，恋战。很多同学说那不写怎么办？你在主线剧情上写创意。
这才是本事。我没有说不能这么写，但是不要在这里浪费太多的篇幅。导致第一第一二目冗长且不紧张，因为也。
你你你你到底急不急，对吧？你急还在那玩鬼屋，这些而且绕容易造成分段非常的割裂。你们同学们你有没有想过去找李雪琴，去找贾边，去找尹正都没有关系。这几场戏之间都没有关系。也就是李雪琴跟着跟到了下一场。但是李雪琴。
那个鬼屋队伍到后面竟然不用，对吧？
李雪琴那个鬼屋的队伍，鬼屋的设定，后面为啥不用呢？然后我们再说三四目对吧？三四目的招数乏力，每一次要解决问题，全是追逐。到了第三幕，第四幕，由于要提节奏，不能停下来搞笑了，所以全都做成了追逐席。
追车就追了三四次。
对吧腿追追了两回吧。
至少两回，说不定都是三回，寺庙里追了一回，然后网吧里腿就追追了一回。
火车站腿着追追了一回，是不是这就这就三次了，然后车坏了，又腿着奔跑。我们说三四目招式法力。有同刚才有同学说，哎呀，我是为了场景丰富，多设计点戏。那你在这设计啊，对不对？你在这设计的又紧张又搞笑，又多点场景，多点元素，那多好，真的到主回到主线剧情上了，出事就是个追。
嘎嘎就是个撵。然后我们再来看一下啊。
有同学说因为反派能力太弱了，对吗？那肯定也有方方面面的原因嘛，所以要去设计，要去改嘛。
还有一个头重脚轻的问题啊，就是女儿的成长给早了，女儿在哪里决定要去拯救她的同学啊？是第二幕啊，抢完骨灰那里，我看到了第25分，然后前面女儿鼓励她做正确的事情，也应该放在第三幕。前面啊我们说他聊起憨豆事件，得到女儿的认可，放在第二幕了。
那里放早了，他前面得不到女儿的认可。
后面得到女儿的认可，反而把女儿坑了，这个节奏才接得紧，这也是个问题，好吧。
来。
那我们就探讨一下这个片子，从这种情况下。
当然了，我们不得不承认啊，还是要说这个片子非常好，是大鹏导演非常优秀的一部作品，但是里面肯定有问题啊，肯定有问题，不这不怕聊，都是熟人可以聊啊。
我们说他的票房和评分都没有达到我认为应该有的高度，怎么去补救都有哪些地方有问题。同学们，坦白说，我说一下我跟大鹏导演的观点啊，坦白说我们俩从个人角度都认为为平安这个角色的动机没有问题。
但是我们俩结合市场也都认为自己过于自信了。因为男人仅凭讲义气或者一句承诺就去做这么多事情。
是我们男性观众的一种自我意淫。
很难推而广之。所以说这是我说人物动机我们其实是可以调的。
那有调有哪几个地方？
我提几个我我跟大鹏导演当时探讨过的问题，大家一块儿去思考。
第一个问题，你们一起跟我思考一下啊。
第一个问题。
喜剧演员扎堆儿。
到底好不好？
这个戏由于是全员喜剧演员。
所以才造就了一2目，他们经常会停下来搞笑。
所以才造就了玛丽根本不给力，就玛丽根本不上劲儿，威胁不了，没有威胁。这是我们探讨的第一个问题。就是如果再来一次还要不要全员喜剧演员？同学们，我为什么跟你们说这部片子，我跟你们讲有个好处，是因为我跟大鹏导演探讨过这些问题。
所以全都是非常实操，非常发自内心的创作者发自内心的问题是吧？这是第一个问题。
这么多喜剧演员扎堆儿。
下次怎么弄？
第二个问题。
韩璐要不要真的做过台？因为如果韩璐真的做过台。
那这个故事的转折，这个故事的牺牲，就这个故事后面的写法就是完全不一样。
而且。
坐过台。
你们就能网报人家吗？
做过台就没有资格捐款吗？做个台就一辈子是个坏人吗？是吧？其实都可探讨，就韩璐要不要真的做过台。对？这件事情我们也仔细的复盘过，你们也可以想一想，我们又下结论啊，因为都是讨论，喜剧演员也带来了很多的呃那个那个票房呀，所以说。
要不要全员喜剧演员，本来也是一个探讨的问题啊？第三。
皮安哥。
可不可以？
喜欢海璐，解决个动机问题，解决个执着的问题。
所以说我们探讨这三个问题，可以没有答案，你也可以有你自己的答案。我们来看一下这个戏，我给大家讲单场啊，有些单场确实是节奏掉下来啊，看一下这个找金总这个包括找这个找他妹这个啊，节奏就掉下来。你们记得吧？十5和17。
给大家看一下啊。
节奏掉的一塌糊涂啊哦十5拍42分没容么意。
不玩。
浪溃。
圈儿啊。
没容意呢。
今天激动梗啊。
那你忙吧哎。
哎。
一呢这这这时间呢。
我哎呦我哎呦，我的哎呦。
往那头走啊，9号房间里头有线索拿来往那边。
吓我干啥，吓他们。
在误导我们。
这个人也是剧情里的一部分。
我呢。
一会儿谁都没行就可拿走。
嗯。
咋来了呢？
人都死了，还传人闲话，不怕遭报应啊。而闲话是关键线索和记生裸娟姐，你是不是说人是小姐了？裸娟姐，紧跟实是我澄心的那不是我说的啊，那杨玉婷说的，你不是哥斯拉啊，我不是哥斯拉，我是大猩猩，不是哥斯拉，是大猩猩，杨玉婷谁呀？
杨宁。
我兼职的时候认识的朋友。
你这么的，你行你下来下来下来打电话给他来啊。
下来呀啊，为平安，我有遥控器咋了？
谁看电视。
哥，你和那个罗娟姐韩露啥关系，啥关系？他是我客户客户问哎哎，那你俩。
没咋地吧。
咋地能咋的嗯。
你等我拿手机摇。
快回来了嗯嗯。
去了花姐嗯，上回你说那个是吧？这段戏很长啊，我们说接下来还有一段戏更长10分钟。这段来找贾冰的戏竟然长达15米。
金董事长办面师。
吃饭呢。
有病，别传染你。
对了，你那个检查结果啊出来了，血脂稍微有点高，反正就当体检了。
寒路人家是老刘走的。
72号。
。
金董事长在里头等你们。
人呢？有事，您对着话筒说，金董事长是话筒的。
这话的。
新董事长很忙，今天云办公。
。
你好。
喂，没开呢。
董事长。
说。
尽会。
首先做一下自我介绍，本人来自说正事。
据可靠消息透露，前不久在一次聚会上，您说给福利院捐款的韩璐是坐台小姐，下一个。
二位请回吧。
我还没唠完呢，一旦金董事长说下一个就代表已经唠完了。那我要想再唠会儿呢，那您得重新排队。
嗯。
你找金董事长办点事儿，97号这段我们就不看了啊，这段10分钟确实有点长了。嗯，这就是我给大家说的啊，第一二幕呢稍微有点冗长，不紧张，事件之间呢有点割裂。然后呢遇到这些事情呢。
不在主线任务上啊，就是这个假边人知导障碍吧，没有什么道理啊，然后呢，其实应该把这样的创造力和篇幅放在三四目解决问题上啊，放在主线剧情上。呃，但是三四目呢就用追逐系来解决问题，这个就就导致了一二目投重三四目脚轻。
同时呢由于女儿的这个成长位置啊放的也这个略早啊，这个节儿我们知道最后是大危机，这个基本上是名盘啊，女儿所以说这个还早啊，这是整个片子几个问题。但是强调一下啊，我们为了学习，我们才去找问题，找其他的可能性，啊，并不代表否认这个片子，好吧。
呃，这部片子啊这部片子还是非常好的啊非常好的。整个片子来说，那谁的事，我认为是。
被低估的一个国产电影啊，整个剧情的完转完这个这个完整度以及这个主题的高度啊都是很不错的。
另外这部片子啊，他其实也讲了很多的这个很多的细节和彩蛋啊，比如说这个反派这个421421实际上就是之前有网络造谣事件啊，那个人的网名就叫421啊，这个一个比较有趣的一个小彩蛋吧啊。另外这个片子其实还有一个彩蛋啊，我不知道大家有没有注意。
为平安的这个出场，这个衣服的颜色，这个头发的颜色，这是谁这是致敬谁呀？
屎黄色的西装。
小丑啊小丑。
另外啊这个白马啊用白马做比喻，其实这也是一些传统的一些暗喻手法。
啊，另外这部片呢还有这个这个。
这个彩蛋就是纪念撒哥啊，纪念撒哥我们说这几年的这部片这类片子啊都都会拿来和这个。
我不是药神做比较啊，嗯，这类片子有一个共同的特点，就是上来是一个小人物啊，小人物然后呢遇到一个事情，然后分段去解决这个问题，分呃基本上是分两个大段，前半段是一个目标，后半段是一个目标。
然后呢，之前的设定呢可以逐步揭开。比如说这个呃人家为什么不愿意跟魏露葬在一起啊，逐步揭开，先是揭开一层纱，说他是做台坐台小姐。
再揭开第二层纱，对吧？呃，他又是弟弟的前前女友。
然后在第二第二段呢把这个事情做到一个升华啊，做到一个升华。最后呢呃主角实现一个牺牲和成长。
呃，伴随着成长必须有牺牲啊，这种小人物成长的这种电影跟到上海了，我们说都会拿来跟我不是药神做比较，实际上确实也非常像啊，就是一个普通人遇到一个事儿，然后呢呃逐步的解决这个问题，也逐步的升华这个问题，牺牲和成长啊，做到牺牲这类电影都是这么写的啊。
同学们在呃通过这个片子，我们学几件事情。第一个学会我不是药神这种小人物成长类型的这种故事戏。上来呢一般打成一个地溜子啊，打臣。然后呢，但是呢他的底线是对家庭负责任，对朋友讲义气，对吧？他可以贪财，他可以好色，但是呢他对家庭和孩子是是是负责任的啊，对朋友也是讲义气。
然后呢让他遇到一个事儿啊，遇到这个事儿，开始呢是一个一种目标。后来呢目标升华。然后呢，解决这个问题的过程中，自己自己遭受一个巨大的牺牲，然后呢同时获得一个成长。这个类型的片子肯定会拿来跟药神做比较的啊，这是我们要学的第一件事情。第二件事情，这个片子比药神高明的。
一点。
是下一个他女儿那条线，所以你要知道啥，我们说他女儿那条线在这个电影当中是一个极大的加分项，因为是同一个主题，另外一个角度。
我们说一个小孩，一个小女孩，实际上更容易遭受网络暴力。
嗯，这个片子的高明之处呢是小女孩那条线。我跟大家讲过啊，像像极了金时漂流记。第三，我说这部片子还有什么可取之处呢？父女关系这个片子的父女关系做的是要比普通的片子好一些的。
普通的片子，你像我不是药神啊，也不不是药神，不是普通的片子啊，但是他是普通的父子关系，会做一个传统型的父子关系。当然也是因为他也没后面也没有给人家给这个孩子戏份嘛。但是在这个戏里，为平安和他的女儿的关系做的非常好。我们说是一个典型的正戏反写。
一个爸爸入狱的入狱好几年的这样一个女儿，她必然是坚强，必然是懂事的，必然是嫌弃爸爸不靠谱的，而且嫌弃就明着嫌弃也没有什么嘛。
我觉得父亲不靠谱，所以少来我的家长会，但是呢我还是喜欢看他直播，还是喜欢跟他沟通的。但是你别来别染头发，对吧？正常的关系是家长要求小孩不要染头发，因为小孩爸爸入狱，小孩缺乏管教，小孩染头发。但是在这部戏里面是爸爸染头发，小孩管教他。
我们说这个父女关系做的也是非常好。而且同学们有有没有发现一个问题啊，就是这个小女孩的演技实在是太好，人家不是喜剧演啊，演技太好啊，所以说这个在这部电影里确实喜剧演员有点多了啊，喜剧演员当然演技好但是他就喜欢演喜剧，你说咋整拦不住他。
所以这部电影还是有很多可以学习的地方的啊，人家的细节的设定，各种彩蛋，各种装造，每一个道具啊，每一个出现的道具都很细心啊，都有都有梗，都是一些那个那个那个很有趣的设计，对吧？那个包括那个大鹏去追那个421追到网吧。
然后那个421拿什么打他？
拿拿拿键盘打的是吧？所以说这个。
还是挺有意思的啊还是挺有意思。这部电影啊细节满满，诚意满满啊，呃，创作者还是给我们呈现了一个非常有趣的非常有趣的一个电影。嗯，我认为他的评分也好，它的票房也好，都被低估了啊，都被低估。当然他有他的问题啊，但是呃我在课上讲过一个片子的问题，我们可以说。
系但是人家当时你说有没有想过这些问题，好不也就是没想到更好的办法呗。好吧，司那这节课就上到这，嗯，拜拜各位。